durante sus siete décadas de reinado
como consorte de la reina isabel segunda
el príncipe felipe se hizo conocido por
su lengua filosa y su sentido del humor
nacido en la familia real griega se
exilió con sólo 18 meses de edad asistió
a la escuela en francia y gran bretaña
un joven y apuesto felipe que conoció a
su prima lejana la princesa isabel
cuando ella tenía apenas 13 años luego
la reina se enamora desde el primer
momento cuando ella era la princesa
isabel en ese momento obviamente él era
solo un joven oficial naval en dar sus
entornos
si bien formaron un vínculo el deber
militar fue lo primero y el príncipe
felipe sirvió en la marina real durante
la segunda guerra mundial adoptando el
apellido bomba ten inicialmente la
familia real consideró que el pobre
príncipe de origen griego no era un buen
partido para isabel aunque felipe se
convirtió en ciudadano británico
naturalizado renunciando a sus títulos
reales griegos y daneses
finalmente los dos tataranietos de la
reina victoria se casaron en 1947 y
luego de que isabel se convirtiera en
reina en 1952 a sus 25 años el duque de
edimburgo la acompañó en numerosos
compromisos oficiales y viajes al
exterior renunciando a una prometedora
carrera naval por el deber real también
lanzó varios proyectos con su nombre
como el premio duque de edimburgo sin
miedo a decir lo que pensaba cometió una
serie de errores memorables una vez le
preguntó a un líder indígena australiano
si en su comunidad todavía se tiran
lanzas en 2011 el duque de edimburgo fue
nombrado lord gran almirante de la
marina fue visto como un regalo de la
reina en su cumpleaños 90
algo frágil en los últimos años felipe
se retiró de la vida pública en 2017 a
los 96 años cumplió más de 22 mil
compromisos públicos a lo largo de siete
décadas